اوضاع انسانيه صعبه تهدد حياه ملايين
السودانيين فالازمه السياسيه والنزاعات
المسلحه والكوارث الطبيعيه وتفشي الامراض
وتراجع الانتاج الزراعي كلها عوامل اجتمعت
معا لتشكل تحديا غير مسبوق للسلطات
الانتقاليه
تحديات تفوق قدره السلطات التي تناشد
المجتمع الدولي للمساعده
كثيره جدا
تتعلق
بمعالجات لاوضاع الانسانيه ولكن
الشاهد انه تحولات كثيره سياسيه واقتصاديه
همم
محليه اقليميه دوليه الامم المتحده قدرت
حاجتها الى مليار و700 مليون دولار بشكل
عاجل لتمكن من تقديم المساعدات الانسانيه
لملايين المحتاجين في السودان
لاكثر من 12 مليون و500,000 شخص لانهم في
حاجه ملحه للطعام ومياه الشرب وخدمات
الصرف الصحي والماوى والتعليم والحمايه
وكل انواع المساعدات من بين هؤلاء الاثني
عشر مليون وهناك اكثر من ثلاثه ملايين
نازح في مناطق النزاعات المسلحه خاصه في
اقليم دارفور والنيل الازرق معظمهم من
النساء والاطفال